my name is Henry Goulding I'm an actor
and I brought a few my watches to share
[Music]
but first I think I ever got was this
hottie a Pasha extra-large communicates
a little bit more classic not too showy
Harry Brown of watches i started doing
travel shows in malaysia and my first
travel show
i thought i deserve something nice and
bit flashy i think i spent my entire
savings on this watch and was eating pot
noodles for the rest of the rest of the
month so the next watch is an Omega
Seamaster deville I bought in Singapore
Singles got a great market for
second-hand vintage watches and this
particular watch was the one that I wore
for the character of Nick Young and
Crazy eight Asians
this one's a big one for me this is a
tutor black bag we needed something that
I could sort of beat around but still be
really classy I have like an Apple watch
to do I call that Steve little anything
I like that Casius that looks like a
casters to me so this is my newest
watches caught a Santos 100 it's got a
heritage this is over 100 years old this
design and they ain't paying me to save
this for sure I'd love definitely bought
all of these Rogers
one of my directors was given the full
gold version and that is pimping I think
if this watch was whispering something
to me right now would be saying I think
we're out of time
and then dramatic
[Music]